don't each other's out for quite a while
and we have a great relationship and a
great relationship with Ireland and we
have a lot to discuss we will be talking
about the obvious and we'll also be
talking about the virus that's it
the world let's see if they've canceled
their big soccer games their
championship games a lot of other games
they've canceled a lot over in Europe
and all over the world so this is a big
world problem we've taken some bold
steps we took the original bolder step
of all when we closed very early with
China that helped us save thousands of
lives and we went very early with Europe
and I think that will likewise be very
good and hopefully we can get it back
together very quickly in terms of
reestablishing with China that's on
track to something happen fairly quickly
because they've made a lot of progress
over the last three or four weeks and
certainly with Europe we think we can go
hopefully very quickly they have some
hotspots that are really bad but they'll
get them better Germany I guess has some
problems now France has some problems
some pretty big problems and Italy of
course is probably record-setting in
terms of what they've gone through Italy
is having a very hard time but we think
we'll reestablish very quickly once this
ends and it's just a question of time
and I think it'll go pretty quickly stay
away from people and wash your hands and
do all of the things that we're supposed
to be doing a little bit anyway but
it'll be it'll go very quickly I know
that we just talking that Ireland's
close their schools and maybe I'd ask
the prime minister to say a little bit
about what you're doing in Ireland
having to do with what we're going to
hello first of all Thank You mr.
president for having us
here today in the run-up to st.
Patrick's Day just another opportunity I
think to show how close Ireland in
America are and how good our
relationship is politically and
economically and everything else and st.
Patrick's Day has become I think a
symbol of how close
Arland America are and how we're going
to continue to stay close into the
future the big concern in Ireland and
Europe at the moment as you know is
covert 19 and we've acted just as you've
acted decisively in the last couple of
days so we have restrictions on travel
for example at Italy for a few days
already but as of tomorrow our schools
will both crashes will close we're
banning all indoor gatherings of more
than 100 people and adver gatherings of
more than 500 and this is all based on
the work health advice from our CDC that
we need to do this for a couple of weeks
to make sure the virus doesn't spread
and we're particularly trying to protect
older people and people with chronic
diseases so we've had about 30 or 40
cases so far one that we were real
concerned of that could rise and that's
why we're taking the action that we're
taking but as you know it's it's a virus
that's gotten pandemic it's all over the
world knows no borders knows no
nationalities and I think we all need to
work together in the world on this an
America in particular you're the richest
country in the world
you've got great scientists great
companies great universities and we need
them working on treatments working on
tests and working on a vaccine because
that's that's that's what will get us on
top of this all right and we're making
great progress there I will say with the
vice president's morning who I know is
heading up the task force for you and he
gave me a lot of confidence that you're
you're getting on top of this and you're
investing right
well they know and I think it was very
made very clear last night who is and
who is it and we'll be discussing that
we'll be discussing some other moves
that we're going to be making and I
think it's gonna work out very well for
everybody but it's a world problem and
you do need separation in some cases you
have some areas that are very heavily
infected and you have said some areas
that aren't frankly but we do need
separation for a little period of time
in some cases president has excluded
Arlen's from the travel ban and one of
the things we have in Ireland is CBP
American border security in Ireland went
through myself yesterday and they're
asking the right questions whether
people has been to China things like
that so what's this idea different then
one of the reasons UK basically has been
it's got the border
it's got first strong borders and
they're they're doing a very good job
they don't have very much infection at
this point and hopefully they'll keep it
that way mr. president there are many
European leaders who are upset that they
weren't consulted about the travel ban
can you explain your rationale for not
consulting with them first before
announcing it last night well we get
along very well with the European
leaders but we had to make a decision
and I didn't want to take time and you
know it takes a long time to make the
individual calls and we are calling and
we have spoken to some of them prior to
some of the majors prior to but we had
to move quickly I mean when they raise
taxes on us they don't consult us and I
think that's probably one of the same
they've done things the European Union
as you know has been some very big tax
raises over the years not so much with
me because I won't put up with it but
they haven't consulted us and in the
case of European Union I've consulted
with many people yeah big impact but
it's a bigger impact and it's also a
human impact which is more important
frankly than the financial when you lose
thousands of additional lives as an
example if I didn't close very very
early Leo you know we closed very
with China and I took a lot of heat
including from you people a lot of heat
they called me everything from a racist
to everything else it was terrible and
the same people then they say oh he
close too fast why did he close most of
us said why did he close with China that
turned out to be a great move what we
did with Europe is this was the time and
China a lot of it came from when you
when you think of what happened to
Europe because it was very fast and very
furious and what happened is a lot of
people went from China into Europe and
Europe suffered tremendously you don't
you see what's going on and so I just
wanted that to stop as it pertains to
the United States and that's what we've
done we stopped mr. president about
campaign rallies about travel outside
the White House you originally had to
travel on the schedule we had some big
rallies we cancelled one that we were
thinking about doing in Las Vegas as you
know and one in Reno Nevada
we had one we had about three of them in
Nevada actually and we had four or five
of them that we were thinking about we
have a big one in Tampa all sold out we
have over a hundred thousand requests
for tickets but I think we'll probably
not do it because people would say it's
better to not do you know we need a
little separation until such time as
this goes away it's gonna go away it's
gonna go away I was watching Scott I was
watching Scott this morning and he was
saying within two months but you know in
the meantime we want to lose as few
people as possible so important and what
is the number as of this morning is it
thirty two you could tell me is it
thirty two deaths
see forever I mean think about the
United States because of what I did and
what the administration did with China
we have 32 deaths at this point other
countries that are smaller countries
have many many deaths thirty twos a lot
thirty twos too many but when you look
at the kind of numbers that you're
seeing coming out of other countries
it's pretty amazing when you think of it
so that's it
we have things that I can do we have
very strong emergency powers under the
Stafford Act and we are we haven't I
mean I haven't memorized practically as
to the powers in that act and if I need
to do something I'll do it have the
right to do a lot of things that people
don't even know about well I don't want
to say that but you know at some point
it may be some of the more minor things
at this point but look we're we're in
great shape compared to other places we
are in really good shape and we want to
keep it that way that's why I did the
band with respect to you I have a lot of
emergency actions that I can do yeah
well we're looking at a lot of things
including paid leave and we're looking
at many things we're also making sure
they're going to get their salaries we
have other workers too and those are
people that work for tips and nobody
thinks about them and we're including
them in a lot of our schedules we're
also making sure that the companies
which are good companies stay solvent
have the money necessary to keep
functioning so we have a lot of things
that we're working on with the financial
markets and it's gonna work out fine you
know where you have to remember the
stock market as an example is still much
higher than when I got here and it's
taking a big hit but it's good all
bounced back and it's going to bounce
back very big at the right time right
now and we're dealing also prior to even
the Stafford Act we're dealing with the
Democrats in Congress we'll see what can
be done I happen to think that a payroll
tax cut would be a very good idea very
just you know distribute its it really
distributes it very evenly among middle
class and other workers I mean many
workers it would be a great thing I
happen to think would be a great thing
even beyond this okay so we're looking
at the payroll tax cut and that won't
come immediately because that's a
stronger measure but we are looking to
do that and I think at the right time
Congress will probably go
with because it really is the most
sensible thing we had the biggest
bankers in the world here yesterday
getting their opinions they all thought
payroll tax cut would be a great thing
it would evenly and quickly distribute a
lot of money do you support the House
bill House Democrat no because there are
things in there that have nothing to do
with what we're talking about so you
know it's not a it's not a way for them
to get some of the goodies that they
haven't been able to get for the last 25
years
just like your prime minister always
they will be did not only welcomed loved
we have minions what is the number down
would you say changes every year it gets
actually bigger about thirty five
million
can you imagine it's got to be one of
our got to be one of our biggest now we
we love the Irish we're gonna be looking
at that we're gonna be talking about
that today it's a very important part of
our conversation that's going to be
actually a very important part of our
conversation well I think there's a lack
of security if they use Huawei there's a
real problem with intelligence and
intelligence security and we'll see what
happens we'll be discussing that point
also can i what but we have them very
heavily tested if an American's coming
back or anybody's coming back we're
testing we have a tremendous testing set
up where people coming in have to be
tested and if they are positive and if
they're able to get through because if
they're frankly if they're if they're
not we're not putting them on planes if
they're if it shows positive but if they
are if they do come here they have to
whip warranty it's going to be a pretty
strong enforcement of quarantine look
the key is you have to have separation
we have to have separation or this thing
takes longer to go away but the the real
really important and I think you can say
this for your country I think we can say
it for a lot of countries for all
countries hopefully it goes away it's
going away
we wanted to go away with very very few
deaths people have you know we call it
cases how many cases do you have well
relative to other countries we have very
few cases relative to certain of the of
the major countries that really have a
bigger problem than us we've offered by
the rat just interestingly I think we
have the greatest doctors in the world
we've offered Iran assistance Iran is
having a tremendous problem and we have
offered Iran assistance if they'd like
it we will help them we'd be glad to
help I think you'll around mr. president
the Pentagon has determined that an
Iranian backed militia fire the Rockets
that killed two American soldiers in
Iraq should they expect a response I'd
rather not say but let's just put it
this way you will see but I can't say I
was working on that last night also they
said a lot of rockets now that hasn't
been fully determined it was Iran as you
know was a was a rebel group but most
likely it looked like it could be backed
by Iran
and we'll see what the response is mr.
president would you like to see the
Prime Minister returns of the White
House next year he's trying to form the
government at home would you like to see
him I always want him to return because
he's a friend we've been doing this now
for quite a while we started off both
both new to the job and yes I would
always like to see him I know they have
other people that I know and I get along
with very well look we get along with
the country but this is a very special
guy we'd like to see you back in back in
Ireland again that's that's of course a
matter for the American people but
President Trump and any American
presence is always welcome
I did hear something about that we had
dinner together in Florida in at
mar-a-lago with the entire delegation I
don't know of what the press aid was
there if he was there he was there but
we did we did nothing very unusual we
sat next to each other for a period of
time had a great conversation
he's doing a terrific job in Brazil and
we'll find out what happens I guess
they're being tested right down right
let's put it this way I'm not concerned
president yesterday we heard from an
emergency room physician in Houston who
had a patient who was showing symptoms
of something tested negative for the flu
this physician wanted to test this
person for coronavirus and got kind of
what this doctor described as an
infinite loop of stupid trying to get
through to the public health agencies in
Texas trying to get permission for this
person to be tested is there something
you can do is the President to try to
cut through those bottlenecks
I was watching they have a million tests
of now they're going to have over the
next few days they're gonna have four
million tests and frankly the testing
has been going very smooth if you go to
the right agency if you go to the right
area you get the test now with that
being said as you know millions of being
produced this is a brand new thing that
just happened but millions are being
produced if you go back and look at the
swine flu and what happened with the
swine flu you'll see how many people
died and how actually nothing was done
for such a long period of time as people
were dying all over the place we're
doing it the opposite we're very much
ahead of everything this person did
contact the correct authorities but they
were closed for the day then he was on
hold for an hour simply trying to get a
test you're talking about one case I
mean I could certainly look into a jet
it's one case I've heard also it goes
very well I watch Scott Gottlieb today
who's was with us and I respect him a
lot I like him and I respect him and he
was talking about how we have so many
different tests and in some cases there
in California where we have
too many and then in other cases
distribution could be a little bit
better for certain areas but we've done
a good job on testing and it was very
interesting you might ask God about it
actually no I have other things to do
I'm very busy
sure it's possible and it's possible I
can also say that we could do it early
we could end it early but I thought it
was an important thing to do because of
what's happening over there well I think
the Democrats won't be having rallies
but nobody showed up to their rallies
anyway so what difference does it make
you know I'll be my rallies are very big
very big rallies and we'll be making a
decision at the appropriate time I mean
the the next one scheduled is for the
25th and that's in Tampa but we'll have
to see whether or not we do know I'm not
gonna do it if I think it's gonna be
negative at all if people are if if we
haven't made that turn yet we'll make
the turn the question is when and the
question is how many people will die and
I don't want people dying that's what
I'm all about
I made a very tough decision last night
in a very tough decision a long time ago
with respect to China I don't want
people dying and that's why I made these
decisions and whether it affects the
stock market or not very important but
it's not important compared to life and
death so I had to make that decision and
frankly the people that are
professionals praised the decision and
it's something I had to do and I think
you'll see the end result is very good
because of it but it'll take a period of
time no and the rallies will make that
decision but at this moment we don't
have I was going to Las Vegas I was
going out to Nevada as I said I was
going to Colorado where we have Cory
Gardner running and he's doing a great
job by the way he's done a fantastic job
but we've postponed that at
we're gonna have Cory coming in here
maybe on Friday we're gonna do our event
from the White House but we have a lot
of things that we're moving around
because of what's happening and because
I want to be here is the nerve center I
want to be right here I don't want to be
flying around in airplanes all over the
place I want to be right here clearly
you're not being advised to avoid some
small games like this but no well
actually people said you know you're
dealing with people that maybe you don't
want to deal with it I said you're right
about that I'm wondering is the White
House medical officer the Secret Service
counseled you against straying too far
from the White House they have not but
it's common sense you know a lot of it
is and what I say is use common sense
like washing your hands and you know
certain things keep a little bit of
distance away that's why the sporting
events are a little bit tough because
you have people sitting in small seats
right next to each other so it's a
little bit tough what happened with the
NBA is pretty incredible but you look
over in in Europe and you see their big
soccer matches were canceled it's pretty
amazing when you when you think of what
happened and how fast this spread to the
world there was one country that was
four countries than it was nine I'm
reading this list every week then it was
13 then it was 22 and now I guess it's
over a hundred countries so it's a it's
an amazing thing how fast this one
spreads this is this is a very fast
spreader any more thoughts about the
Tokyo Olympics no I just wished the
Prime Minister he's a great friend of
mine
Prime Minister Robby and I wish him luck
they did such a perfect job that venues
are incredible he was proudly showing me
pictures of what they'd done the last
time I was with him this is before this
came up and I said what a job and they
built it very well they built it on
budget right on even under budget and
their beautiful facilities I don't know
it's very possible it's very possible
that for the Olympics maybe I just can't
see having no people there in other
words not allowing people maybe and this
is just my idea maybe they postpone it
for a year maybe they do that if that's
possible maybe they maybe that's not
possible I guess it's never happened
with the Olympics although I think there
was interruption for Wars right it was
canceled or interruption but I would say
maybe they postpone it for a year it's a
shame because really I'm you know I used
to be in the real estate business as you
probably heard they built some real and
I built beautiful buildings and they
built some really beautiful buildings so
you make this recommendation to you for
instance a lobby no now they're very
smart they're gonna make their room but
you know I like that better than I like
having empty stadiums all over the place
I think if you cancel it make it a year
later that's a better alternative than
doing it with no crowd
well we didn't shake hands today and we
looked at each other we said what are we
gonna do you know it's sort of a weird
feeling I think we said at the same time
we did this you know I just got back
from India and I didn't shake any hands
there and it was very easy because they
go like this and Japan goes like this
they were ahead of the curve okay no we
looked at each other we said and we also
had a lot of press staring at us right
we're saying guys we supposed to shake
hands and when his group of very smart
representatives came in who I know
likewise we didn't it's a very strange
feeling and I was never a big hand
shaker as you probably heard but once
you become a politician shaking hands is
very normal and it's a very strange
feeling when people that you know and
like they walk up and say hi and they're
just like this we were saying it's a
little bit it feels it all the different
almost feels feels impersonal it feels
like you're being rude but we just can't
afford to think like that for the next
few weeks and mr. president could you
talk about the trickle through effect of
everything that we're seeing here it's
like when you when you cancel an NBA
season you're losing all of the revenue
the team's out vendors and
that way all through the entire economy
yet it has an obvious effect the only
thing worse can be that you lose
thousands and thousands of people more
than you would have lost if you did it
the way we're doing it so it certainly
has an impact and again we're very much
working with the states because you know
the states are a smaller form of
government they can control individual
arenas and individual things better and
it's different for different areas some
areas have no problem whatsoever in our
country and others do so we're working
with the governors of the various states
and it's I think it's working very well
I think the relationship has been very
well good with California and some
others that that in particular have been
hit whoever it is I hope they make their
choice soon I thought it was gonna be
everybody thought it was gonna be Bernie
and I've said Elizabeth Warren if she
waited for you know she waited that
extra three days four days and Super
Tuesday was a disaster he would have won
every one of those states or almost I
think almost every one of those states
Maine Massachusetts Texas you take a
look at the states that were very close
and many of her I would say most of her
I would almost say all of hers but many
of her votes would have gone to him so
had she left prior to Super Tuesday with
just a few days he would have right now
been declared virtually the winner would
have been over but now we have Joe and
I'm very happy to run against Joe one of
the reasons I ran for president is
because of Joe and the job they did so
it's one of the reasons so in a way it's
in a way it's a you know it's it's maybe
the way it should be
but it looks to me like it would be
Biden would win
we haven't discussed that yet is it a
possibility yes if somebody gets a
little bit out of control if an area
gets too hot you see what they're doing
in New Rochelle which is which is good
frankly it's the right thing but then
it's not enforced it's not very strong
but people know they're they're being
watched New Rochelle that's a hot spot I
did well I asked them what's going on
and they're having a dispute with Russia
this is something that drove oil prices
down and one thing I can tell you is oil
prices that are at a point now that I
would have dreamed about because the
gasoline prices are going to be coming
way down they'll be coming way down so
with gasoline prices coming down that's
like a tax cut frankly that's like a big
tax cut not a little tax cut for the
consumer so there's something about that
that I like thank you very much
everybody thank you very much